let's hear from people in the audience
the most important people
because without you I'm a guy in a room
with a mic and no one's listening and
it's sad okay we don't want that let's
start today with rose I guess calling
from the United States is that you Rose
yes can you hear me clearly yes the
United States is so General you could
you could be anywhere you know
true uh privacy preserving so um did you
watch the launch of uh dsls and the
Artemis One mission you know I did not
see it but I saw you know a little bit
of a replay
oh it was it was unexpectedly moving and
spectacular like the plume itself from
the rocket was like a mile long yes
that's a lot of pollution it sounds like
rose
well I don't say it's hydrogen and
oxygen so it's mostly ionized gases it's
just water vapor oh is that right is
that true
uh the the first stage is hydrogen
oxygen the solid rocket boosters they
they do burn uh fuel
um but yeah most of the output is just
water so well if that's true then I I
like water water is good
at this point 10 years a decade to get
to this launch and the program so far
has cost around
27.5 billion dollars yeah in in 2022
right and
I am I'm just it and the reason why we
have this is like a 62.5 offer Twitter
in like Elon units
um so the reason why we have that is
because a single senator from the great
city of Alabama Center Shelby I wanted
to save jobs in a state so we have an
entire 27.5 billion dollar program
because of him not because like people
at Nasa wanted to do this and this was
the best technical Way Forward but
mostly because of uh Congressional and
Senate interference in the process
um have you given thought to how we can
get past this kind of corruption
well I would like to see one of the
things in general I mean I can't speak
to the exact process you're describing
because I did not follow it clearly as
closely as you did but one of the things
I would prefer to see when it comes to
everything in Under the Umbrella of
Science and I would include space
exploration there is if there could be
a way to de-politicize some of the
decisions like of course the jobs for a
lot of the spending will
disproportionately be in some states and
not others that there's no real way
around that you're not going to be able
to say let's do space exploration and
divide the money equally among 50 states
it's not going to happen so I know uh
sorry uh so if you're presenting a
contract like when Boeing presents a
contract or even SpaceX they actually
make sure that they have suppliers from
all 50 states
from North Dakota for this project
sheet on that that's great but I think
the point still stands that you don't
have exactly equal dollar for dollar in
job for job division across all 50
states so there's going to be some
elected officials that will be more
incentivized than others maybe to go
with a particular approach I don't know
if we need
a non-partisan advisory committee which
there I'm sure it probably exists at
least in some name but clearly it's not
effective enough because you still get
these extremely political uh outcomes I
don't know what it is it's something
that needs to be equivalent to the ways
we could re draw districts more fairly
but I would love to see more scientists
involved in figuring out rather than
doing it this way which is most
appealing to these Senators we should do
it this way which is actually where the
most exciting potential rewards exist
based on where the science is and I
don't know what the answer is Rose as to
exactly how you do that
so
um in Europe
um like a CERN for example gets a
specific uh inflation or just a
contribution from member states member
states get to get sent people to their
uh Council which sits on top and like
basically votes on spending Decisions by
CERN uh if CERN wants to build a big
particle collider they start decades in
advance like they've already started for
uh saving money and setting aside that
then financing and everything else for a
client that's going to be built in the
2040s to the 2050s right so they plan in
like a 30 40 year time Horizon NASA is
constrained by the yearly budget and
they have to spend every single penny in
that yearly budget and they're not
allowed to save money that makes sense
yep absolutely that I totally understand
that mechanism I I do think that having
to plan 30 or 40 years ahead also makes
the the progress at least seems slower
and I don't know if that will work for
an American audience that wants to see
action more quickly but I think we
should explore all of these options and
I really appreciate the call Rose
a pleasure talking
to you there is Rose from the United
States